here's what would happen if a magnitude  20 earthquake shook the earth  a naturally occurring magnitude 20  earthquake is actually impossible as  earth's circumference isn't big enough  to produce this strong of an earthquake  however one way that a magnitude 20  quake could occur would be because of a  massive asteroid impact you would feel  the shaking for at least five minutes  and aftershocks would go on for hours  it would trigger tsunamis and volcanic  eruptions  not to mention even more earthquakes a  magnitude 20 earthquake would produce  more than enough energy to overcome the  gravitational binding energy and would  literally destroy our planet so